PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Can I
get some milk and sugar
with my coffee please?
SPEAKER: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Now that
is some awesome coffee.
Translation is fun, isn't it?
Well, stay with me as we explore
custom translation models
to power global apps.
Welcome to "AI Adventures" where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
I'm Priyanka
Vergadia, and today we
are talking about custom
translation models.
I was in Peru last
year, which is mostly
a Spanish-speaking country.
I do not speak Spanish,
so I had to rely
on Google Translate for even
minor things such as can I
get milk in my coffee, please?
Now imagine if I was to go live
and work in Peru for a year,
helping developers implement
machine learning and AI maybe.
The machine-learning field has
unique terms and references
to mathematical concepts
which might not be captured
in a standard dictionary.
For a custom use case like this,
the standard Translation API
may not be sufficient.
To provide the
best experience, I
would need to make sure things
don't get lost in translation,
and that would need a custom
model specific to the ML and AI
terminologies to
communicate effectively
with the Spanish-speaking
developers.
This is probably true
in your field as well.
That's where AutoML
Translation comes to rescue.
AutoML Translation lets
you create your own custom
translation models
so that translation
queries return results
specific to your domain.
To understand this further,
let's take another example.
Imagine you run a
financial-reporting purpose
that has an opportunity
to expand to Peru, India,
and France.
Those markets require that
your time-sensitive financial
documents are
translated in real time.
AutoML Translation can help you
automate the translation job
for over a hundred language
pairs in a scalable way,
allowing you to enter those
newer markets quickly.
Now, you might be asking
yourself, when would
I use AutoML over
the Translation API?
Translation API does a great
job with general-purpose text,
and with advanced
glossary features
you can take it further by
providing a dictionary of words
or phrases.
I covered this in detail in the
previous episode linked below.
But there are times when
you don't have a glossary
or know exactly which
word translations
you want to control.
AutoML Translation
shines in those cases
in that last mile between
generic translation
tasks and specific
niche vocabularies.
What's amazing is
AutoML's custom model
is built on top of the
generic Translation API
model for domain-specific
content that matters to you.
Now let's say you've established
that you need a custom
translation model.
How would you create one?
Well, we will just prepare
and source the data
and feed it into
AutoML Translation.
It then trains, deploys,
and serves the model,
and provides us with
an easy interface
to evaluate and test it.
It creates an easy-to-use
REST API to make predictions.
High-quality data is
critical ingredient
in creating an effective
AutoML Translation model.
As a general best practice,
make sure your sentence pairs
do the best-possible job of
covering the vocabulary, usage,
and grammatical quirks of your
industry or the area of focus.
For more details,
I've included a link
in the description for
some best practices of how
to assess and source your data.
Once we have the data, we head
over to the AutoML Translation
UI and create the data set by
selecting the source and target
language.
Upload the files
from your computer,
and select the folder in
Cloud Storage for these files
to be stored.
Then successfully uploaded,
we can review our data set
and the sentence pairs.
With the data all set, we
are ready to train the model.
But this step can take
several hours, depending
on the amount of data.
So let's grab coffee
in the meantime.
All right, it looks like
our training is complete,
and right here it is showing
us the high-level metrics
for our model and its BLEU
or Bilingual Evaluation
Understudies score, which takes
a ground-truth translation
and compares it to a
machine translation.
The more overlap between the
human and machine output,
the higher the BLEU score.
You can see the score
for Google's base
model and your custom
model as well as
the difference between them.
In this case, we see a boost
of a few points over the base
model.
Now the moment of truth.
Let's head over to our
Predict tab to test our model.
We can even compare the
results from our custom model
to the Google NMT, which is
the Neural Machine Translation
model, to see the difference.
In this episode, we learned
how AutoML Translation
helps you create high-quality,
production-ready, custom
translation models quickly.
How are you using the
AutoML Translation
model in your use cases?
Share with me in
the comments below.
Thank you for watching
this episode of "Cloud AI
Adventures."
And if you enjoyed it,
click that Like button,
and be sure to subscribe to get
all the latest episodes right
when they come up.
I look forward to
seeing you next time
on "AI Adventures,"
where we will
talk about federated learning.